A long time ago a great disturbance was felt
in the force as millions of voices cried out
in terror, and were suddenly silenced. But
c'mon, could the Death Star really blow up
a planet?!
It’s Star Wars day, you guys (screams)
Hey jedis and siths, Trace Windu here for
DNews -- get it?
Like…
Mace?
Okay…
A key plot point in the original Star Wars
story was the destruction of the planet Alderaan
by the Death Star as a show of force to the
Rebel scum. Then, after the destruction, an
asteroid field formed around Alderaan's star,
but c'mon... would all this really happen?!
Yes, the movie is science fiction, but when
have we nerds ever let that stop us from sciencing
the sh*t out of something?
Okay, first we need to know how much energy
it takes to blow up a planet, then we can
work out if the Death Star can blow up something
so much bigger than itself. Alderaan is an
M-Class planet, right?
It's earth-like and similarly sized. Three
nerdy researchers at the University of Leicester
calculated how much power the Empire would
have to impart into the planet to get it to
overcome its own gravity and fly in all directions.
It's a really big number: 2 octillion joules.
The World Energy Consumption is only 56 billion
joules!
So these numbers are pretty difficult to fathom.
Let's put it in perspectives we can comprehend,
sort of…
The power of our whole sun is 380 septillion
joules, astronomers call this ONE solar luminosity.
Ahh, small numbers.
So, the energy required to blow up a planet,
according to these researchers would be 5.2
solar luminosities, or the amount of energy
of our Sun releases in a week. Which is pretty
insane. Phil Plait, Bad Astronomer and internet-winner
extraordinaire, says depending on the planet's
size though, it could be more like 582,000
solar luminosities!
That would take 57 quadrillion megaton nuclear
bombs to blow up!
I love me some Plait, but for the sake of
simplicity let's go with the students… we
want it the answer to be in reach, after all.
To generate all that energy, we need to understand
how the Death Star is powered. According to
authors in the Extended Universe, I know,
its hypermatter reactor is as powerful as
"several main-sequence stars." As we're basing
these numbers on our own Sun's power of one
solar luminosity, the Death Star may throw
power around equivalent to say seven of our
sun -- or seven solar luminosities!
THATS WAY MORE THAN the 5.2 needed to blow
up a planet!
Note: our sun is a relatively small main-sequence
star, so this is a pretty conservative estimate.
But, it could be even easier than all that.
Shooting a big laser at a planet would just
heat it up -- and you'd have to get through
all that mass to reach the core and vaporize
it… very unlikely. Popular Mechanics got
a bunch of SciFi authors together and brainstormed
the problem. My favorite hypothesis is that
the superlaser fired by the Death Star is
positronic; a positron is a positively charged
antimatter twin of an electron!
If they fired a pure antimatter beam at Alderaan
it would cause massive matter-antimatter explosions!
When matter and antimatter meet, they annihilate
each other in a huge release of energy. Because
these antimatter-matter reactions are so powerful,
according to author Ethan Siegel, you'd only
need the amount of antimatter equivalent to
0.00000002 percent of the mass of the planet
being destroyed!
Even Phil Plait agrees that might do it!
But then what?
In 1977, George Lucas described Alderaan as
a planet in a system, it not exactly canon,
but other planets definitely exist. When the
Death Star's superlaser destroys it what happens
to those six other planets?
Not too much. Asteroids accelerated by the
release of heat and pressure from inside the
planet would shoot toward the outer reaches
of their solar system, but overall the Alderaan
system would be about the same… the mass
of the planet would distribute around a new
asteroid belt; and the system would move on…
Think of it like Mars' moon Phobos, it's set
to be torn asunder in the next 50 million
years, but it won't disrupt the orbit, the
mass is going to be pretty much the same.
A quick wobble, then back to business as usual.
Look, this is science fiction, it's a fanciful
story. But the best part about science is
it can make these stories feel more real.
Arthur C. Clarke's Third Law of Scientific
Prediction is, "Any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from magic."
If the Empire can wield many times the power
of our whole sun in a single spacecraft -- it
would be like magic to us. But of course,
no matter how powerful the Death Star was,
it is insignificant, next to the power of
the Force. I'd like to thank Dr. Natalie Hinkel
for helping me with all this stellar math,
btw!
She's awesome.